ladies and gentlemen it's no secret that
times are tough inflation's going crazy
a bunch of people are out of work
there's a worldwide pandemic yet if you
listen to the internet it's never been
easier to get rich so while i've got
some bigger investigations going on i
always like to dedicate a few videos to
this new breed of insanity that exists
on the internet that tells you that
getting rich is only one click away
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffeezilla the internet detective and
today we're investigating how all these
zoomers are becoming zillionaires right
you guys know that i have the 10 million
dollar city which is very real very
legit authenticated but what has never
been audited are all these tick tock
accounts that are coming out of the
woodwork they're all millionaires it's
amazing and i want to follow their
financial advice we need to listen to it
together so you can know what to look
for because you may think jay powell has
you over the barrel but it's not true
losing seven percent to inflation you
can become a millionaire too if you
follow these simple steps this is how i
stole million dollar art people is a
digital artist whose prolific work has
been seen everywhere and as of recently
one of the most expensive artists
currently alive the final bid 69 million
dollars oh my god he came to the city
yesterday to screen the documentary 1 37
pm made for him
so i approached him with a
plan hey people can i show you a magic
trick
okay so can you just draw a stick figure
real quick okay not much of an artist
okay thanks man
[Music]
and now i have a real beeple drawing
hanging in my home whoa
okay i take it back it's actually pretty
smart i thought it was gonna be some
lame uh hack you know i copied and
pasted your nft i don't have a hat to
tip you but uh very good fair enough
what's next screenshotting nfts equals
becoming a millionaire what's the
equivalent of robbing a
been paying for bank
i've been selling them
this is the uh modern way to get rich
guys you don't like it
take it up with the modern economist
dude uh this is what the what we do now
we
screenshot board apes you just sit
around your house and your millionaire
that's what it is can we just all admit
that nfts are really weird if it's just
a picture of a little profile picture of
an ape it's not worth anything this is
the modern tulip bulb moment boys this
man this mad man is stealing all your
value absolutely for free
scammer gets scammed what can i say
honestly we should just have like a you
wouldn't steal a car
you wouldn't steal a house
why would you screenshot an nfd
that's honestly where we're going to
dude pretty soon people are then we're
gonna put out campaigns don't control c
control v mike artwork guys up next we
have a balding sad man in his 30s maybe
40s might be a glimpse into the future
am i right guys that's a sad joke to
make a loan in a room recording to
yourself right there okay guys here's
next we have a tick tock here my ship
would now be worth one billion dollars
no way
i just
got a message from a couple of mates and
they told me that
this token called shiba inu
its cryptocurrency
has gone up 67 million percent
since
since january last year
it's you're proud
it's all a fugazi dude it's a fugazi
listen this uh modern bull run this
modern crypto wave
dude it ain't lasting just listen to
that number like think about it is there
anything that could support this
substantiate this think about a normal
stock yeah apple it went up 67 million
percent
in one year yeah really in one year can
you believe it the pink sheets 67
million percent no this doesn't make any
sense
now in january last year
i was browsing
reddit and i came across
a subreddit that recommended buying
these meme tokens and one of them was
ship shiba inu now
at the time i put two thousand dollars
into it and i left it for
a couple of weeks and i lost 300 pounds
uh i sold it at a loss
anyway it turns out that would now be
worth
one billion dollars if i haven't sold it
hey look that's your average trader for
you right there right you buy high you
sell low and you don't wait till the
actual high
as soon as it dips panic sell every time
dude that's the average crypto trader in
a net show for you how can you go to
work after that you know what i mean
like just the fact you lost that much
money must just eat away at this man at
night honestly the truth is though uh
you could have never known which meme
coin is gonna pop off that's the problem
with them there's millions of them so
most people do lose money and so you
were probably right to sell it but hey
sometimes you should have won the
lottery if you just held on to the
ticket now up next guys we have a very
special contribution
to our lesson on how to become rich and
this is one of the island boys now as
you guys know the pinnacle of
talent because i'm an island boy and
i've been trying to make oh i'm an
island boy
now when they went viral when they got
millions of hits immediately the world
wanted to know what do these guys think
about finance because that's what
crypto's about guys we've thrown out
the uh the the the seasoned investors
and we've asked the island boys which
way modern man what's the new crypto
secret crypto eye i'm just trying to
make it i'm a crypto island trying to
make it i'm a crypto island go to the
top yeah so what they saying
crypto
you know stop of all the things i've
done today i feel worse for watching
that no no no no stop the video stop the
music
we shouldn't be doing this we shouldn't
be
airing this i'm part of the problem i'm
sensationalizing these idiots this is
what this is what mass entertainment is
nowadays
having an existential crisis right now
the island boys have given me an
existential cri this is a disaster
obviously don't invest in crypto island
it'd be hilarious
actually it just occurred to me it'd be
hilarious if somebody invested in two
thousand dollars they sold because i
said so and then you know a year later
it's worth a billion dollars
crypto island got up one million percent
in the last year would be just my luck
listen hey look look this whole bubble
can't last forever guys so enjoy the
ride while you can okay all this
nonsense of oh we went up a million
percent in a year and ain't happening
for long listen trust me now coming to
things that aren't going to change
anytime soon
no i'm just kidding
i think this one's about the gender pay
gap sorry sorry
i'll prove to you that the gender pay
gap does not exist the reason why men
make more is because they choose higher
paying jobs like lawyer doctrine oh here
we go here's the propaganda
but women choose lower paying jobs like
female lawyer female dog okay
sorry you had me you had me in the first
half dude
oh my gosh that's pretty funny
by the way guys i just wanted to say
real quick while we're here all credits
go to um tick tock investors the twitter
account great great account very funny
memes go follow him and don't forget to
pump zilla of course as well now this
honestly makes so much sense of all the
data i'd seen i had felt so bad for
women for years and then i really i
didn't realize they were picking
different jobs
i'm just kidding of course we respect
all women here equal pay for equal work
that's what it's all about boys
um now our next guy
is talking to the men of the room this
man is an older brother teaching his uh
little brother the lessons of finance
that he has learned let's tune in
dude come out to texas we're getting
rich out here he said i can't i have
class i said
school the crypto markets
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh dude you know what sucks it's like
okay this is like legit funny and then
also
we're in this weird time where there
hasn't been a bear market for like 12
years so you could just have stuck your
money sort of anywhere um in this like
modern market where everything just goes
up up up up up
and you're kind of fine i mean assuming
you weren't a total idiot or you
allocated funds but oh
when this market turns i'm not saying
i'm going to be happy about it because
i'm not i'm not objectively i'm not
but it'll be nice it'll be nice to have
the markets make sense again guys listen
the value investor they have been very
sad for a very long time let me tell you
that all those guys studying stocks all
day to try to figure out which ones are
going to pop they're getting
outperformed by people
like this
literally you go to your mba program at
harvard and then you're about you're
about to finish your four-year degree
some guy pulls up in a mclaren goes that
says this
it's hard not to cry a little inside
when you see this stuff oh man it's
funny although just showing a price that
goes up doesn't mean anything
a lot of the people who are talking
about crypto now literally have bought
here
they they tell you they bought down here
but actually what they did is they got
into uh social media and decrypto at the
same time which is right here now guys
our next meme here is what not to do
when you're dealing with getting rich
guys you don't want to do this right you
want to rip the crypto markets you don't
want to do this this guy says y'all i
put my entire net worth into squid
gamecoin what do i do and then we see
that he
made the classic mistake of buying high
and selling low guys that's not what you
want to do you want to buy low it's very
counterintuitive not a lot of economists
have figured this out you buy low
and you sell high so classic mistake by
this guy
i hope that he can improve himself and
become a better human for society nice
try buddy nice try what do we have next
here i bet you're asking uh a bunch of
guys here standing on the street nay we
have the next fortune 500 most powerful
people in america
[Music]
this is why men get paid more
already dead wait are they chanting
because it's the bored apes is that what
this is all about they're just ah just
another just another thing it just
that has absolutely gone crazy bored
apes this month they're all worth it's
like a million dollars to get a board
ape now maybe 10 million maybe an arm
maybe you just sell your whole leg eat a
board ape absolutely crazy that these
djinns figured it out man hey you got to
put your hat off to him what's the stock
market
what what's the stock market
what did you just say
what's
the stock market
what's the stock market
i don't know what are you poor
[Music]
what is it
what's the stock market oh my gosh
[ __ ] god i just want you to explain
the internet
about the internet
you know about grabs
charts
what is it
what is it
don't ask me to explain it to you okay
listen if you don't know what it is
you're not rich you're not part of that
special club dude tabitha do you even
day trade no get out of this apartment
no really if you're not options trading
with 100x leverage i can't even talk to
you
listen guys
this is how you get rich in the 21st
century i mean it's jokes it is it is
jokes but at the same time because you
should absolutely not do this you will
fail at the same time there are idiots
buying nfts becoming rich there's idiots
buying shib and they could have been a
billionaire it's absolute nonsense don't
ask me to explain it to you in fact i
know
finance guys who are looking at things
going
like they're going crazy internally and
i feel bad for them because they've
spent their whole life studying the
market and none of it makes sense right
now but does that mean you've thrown
since out the window no because the
truth is you can't replicate those
results because they're one in a million
you just hear about them on social media
so don't be stupid don't go into this
instead practice good financial sense
guys that means no meme coins it means
invest in what you understand it means
be conservative don't invest more than
you can afford to lose have a risk
tolerance all these things will
safeguard you when we inevitably run
this economy off the cliff like we seem
to be doing so be safe out there and if
any of these tips helped you become rich
hey go ahead pump the stock guys it's
absolutely free i have to tell you guys
it's absolutely free because apparently
there's some crypto called zillow which
i'm absolutely not affiliated with i
would never promote i have to tell you
guys explicitly only pump the stock by
liking subscribing thank you so much for
watching as always big investigations
coming we'd just like to get some of
these more daily videos out to you guys
because oh we know you got to consume
the content okay so there it is love ya
hope you had a good one i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling